all right grammarians let's get down to
it and start talking about possessive
pronouns a possessive pronoun is a
pronoun that we use to show possession
of something which is just sort of a
fancy way of saying you have it
so possession equals
having
stuff
now we can essentially divide possessive
pronouns in half
because on this side of the divide we
have a list of pronouns that behave like
adjectives
and on this side we have a group of
pronouns that behave like nouns
i'll list them and then we'll give some
examples so the possessive pronoun that
behaves like an adjective for me is my
the possessive pronoun that behaves like
a noun for me is mine
our behaves like an adjective ours
behaves like a noun your behaves like an
adjective yours behaves like a noun her
behaves like an adjective hers behaves
like a noun
his behaves like an adjective his
behaves like a noun it behaves like an
adjective it behaves like a noun and
there behaves like an adjective and
theirs behaves like a noun now i'd like
to point out that nowhere in any of
these words does there appear such a
thing as an apostrophe
that little guy
i know this much is true there are no
apostrophes in possessive pronouns
so it's not
it's not hours
it's hours like that it's not yours
with an apostrophe like that it's yours
with no apostrophe likewise it's not
hers
his
it's this is the big one
i mean something entirely different
or theirs
across all varieties of english the
possessive pronouns don't have any
apostrophes in them
so this is a very handsome looking chart
if i do say so myself but it doesn't
really do
the work of explaining what i mean by
saying my behaves like an adjective and
mind behaves like a noun so let me get
some example sentences down and we'll
see what i mean
so let's say that there was a book that
i owned
how would i talk about it i could do it
two different ways using these
possessive pronouns i could say
that is my book
and here my is working as an adjective
that modifies and describes book
or i could say
that book is mine
and here we're using is to connect book
to mine and so in that case we're using
mine as a noun
how do we know it's acting like a noun
because we can use it independently of
the word book so if someone says to me
david where is your book i can say
mine is on the bedside table
nowhere in this sentence does the word
book appear but we can use mine
independently because we've established
in a previous sentence the thing we're
talking about
is this book
so let's talk about my co-worker greece
nice fella
and let's say that garish has a very
nice hat
we would
say that
is
garish's
hat
this is what we'd call a possessive noun
but talking of garish again we could say
that
is
his hat
now we're using that possessive pronoun
as an adjective
to modify hat
whose hat is it it is his hat
if we wanted to use the personal pronoun
that acted like a noun we would say that
hat is his
and we can also use his independently of
the word hat by saying
by saying his is the hat with polka dots
so we've got two piles of possessive
pronouns here and one pile behaves like
adjectives my our your her his it's
there and the other behaves like nouns
mine ours yours hers his it's theirs
and remember
none of them contain an apostrophe
you can learn anything
david out